today on the matt well show we're
supposed to celebrate because for the
first time
a child has three legal fathers listed
on her birth certificate
but i don't feel much like celebrating
i'll explain why if it's not already
obvious also five headlines including
governor cuomo
facing political disaster due to his
sexual harassment scandal but how is it
that
this is the scandal that takes him down
and not the nursing home scandal that
resulted in the deaths of thousands of
elderly people
and also the cancel mob is coming for dr
seuss we'll talk about that in our daily
cancellation
we'll discuss the left's latest
linguistic innovation which is
women but with an x instead of an e all
of that and much more today on the matt
wall show
the new york post announces the big news
a baby
with three dads this is supposed to be a
a historic first
a major milestone in human history and
it certainly would be
if there actually existed a baby with
three actual fathers
turns out and this is no surprise to the
dwindling minority with a rudimentary
grasp of basic human biology
that the child merely has a birth
certificate with the names of three
dudes written on it
here's the post with the details it says
a gay polyamorous california throuple
made history in 2017 when they became
the first family in the state to list
three parents on a birth certificate
their reproductive journey in legal
battle to become fathers to piper now
three
is detailed in three dads and a baby
written by one of her dads dr
ian jenkins jenkins and his partners
jeremy hodges and dr
alan mayfield don't see their family
which now also includes their son
parker as unusual
well of course it is by definition
unusual
it's not possible for a thing to make
history and not be
unusual indeed unusual is the most
polite and measured thing that i can say
about this particular arrangement but
more from the post it says
jenkins met mayfield a psychiatrist
while they were completing so maybe
should tell you a little something about
the psychiatry industry
well anyway he met a psychiatrist while
they were completing their medical
residencies in boston the two were
together for eight years when hodges
who works at a zoo hospital came into
the picture although their relationship
with hodges began as a friendship things
quickly turned romantic after five years
of
throppledum the trio started seriously
discussing parenthood when friends
offered to donate
their leftover embryos to them leftover
embryos isn't it inspiring to hear
human life referred to this way like
it's a slab of meatloaf sitting in a
tupperware container in the fridge
i got some leftover embryos let me go
grab them i think i got a couple in the
truck i'll go i'll go take a look
as it turns out the leftover embryo i.e
human life
wasn't viable and the next attempt tempt
also didn't take so they took several
several tries just tossing out the
embryos no big deal just human life
finally um a helpful friend gave them
some of her eggs which
were then fertilized in a laboratory and
implanted in the uterus of another
friend
meanwhile some fancy footwork was
performed with the help with the help of
lawyers and
tens of thousands of dollars of legal
fees and then presto chango just like
magic
a child with three dads was born which
is to say
a child with one father a mother she'll
never know who was conceived in a petri
dish
brought to term in a rented uterus and
placed in the care of three men who
immediately set out to monetize her
existence
with a self-congratulatory memoir was
born
tomato tomato i suppose if you're
feeling not terribly excited about our
new and improved society where babies
can have three dads and no mom
that's because you're a normal insane
person
as a normal and sane person the whole
thing probably seems to you rather
i don't know unnatural disordered
you likely have the impression that the
interests of the children aren't being
taken much into account here sure
the men feel great about their dad trio
but their emotional needs
aren't the primary concern of normal
and sane people we're worried about the
children
who are being treated more as fashion
accessories than human beings
to respect their humanity is to
acknowledge that children need mothers
too
it is an absurd and damnable idea that
the role of the mother can be adequately
replaced
just by adding more dads into the
equation
i'm still not exactly sure what the
exchange rate is like you add uh
add you know so you have one dad that's
that's that equals
a dad and then you've got two dads that
equals a mom
so each dad equals one mom how does it
work exactly
add four more dads and you have two moms
a dad
but if adding dads is the plan why stop
at three why not four
dads four dads five dads six dads seven
it's beginning to sound like a creepy
children's book that i'm sure somebody
will eventually write
this is not a rhetorical question it's
something we really need to think about
because the floodgates are officially
open and have been for some time
once society moves away from the nuclear
family not just in practice
but in a categorical denial that it is
the ideal family structure at all
then there's no remaining boundary no
limiting principle
this is where the so-called slippery
slope argument comes in and it's why
those who warn about slippery slopes are
usually proven correct even as the left
laughs and guffaws at the whole notion
that perhaps sometimes one thing might
lead to another
i mean they call something a slippery
slope argument as if
simply labeling it slippery slope is
enough to uh debunk it it's not
yes oftentimes slopes are slippery
oftentimes one thing leads to another
the point with the slippery slope is
that when you tear down a boundary
without any idea as to where to rebuild
it
or you get rid of a words definition
without even a suggestion as to what its
new definition
definition ought to be then you have
obviously that it would seem by design
scent sent this new boundary-less
undefinable thing tumbling into insanity
and incoherence
you haven't actually moved the boundary
or changed the definition of the thing
but simply destroyed it
as i've observed many times this is the
process playing right playing out right
now with respect to gender
we're told that the word woman no longer
means adult human female which is what
it meant
since the dawn of time so what does it
mean
if it's not that then what is it
those who seek to erase the words
traditional definition have it turns out
no plans for giving it a new one they
don't seek to promote
or you know a new or expanded concept of
womanhood
but to annihilate the very concept
itself
it is not really a slope but a free-fall
plunge into
obliteration each new stage in our moral
and logical descent is predictable and
inevitable if our biological identity
has no meaning and can be changed on a
whim
then the same will be done with age and
race and every other aspect of our
identity
it's not a question of if
it will happen it is already beginning
to happen
because there's no reason why it
wouldn't happen
now that the precedent has been set and
the logical and moral barriers
preventing it from happening have been
removed
and so with marriage and family it's the
same
we have seen three men call themselves
dead
soon that's not going to be the
strangest or most disturbing combination
give it enough time and even the
self-professed conservatives will be
defending the three dad concept as
valid and equal while maybe maybe
offering polite pushback to the newer
you know
four dads and three sex robots family
units
i wish i was exaggerating but this is
the path that we put ourselves on
when we moved away from the mother
father nuclear family structure
that was we had it right the first time
that was right
everything after that is wrong
and once you give up on that
there is no end the truth is that
every child needs and deserves both a
mother and a father
we have to preserve that or preserve
nothing
there is no middle option there is no
compromise with moral insanity
you either fight it with all you have on
every field of battle
never giving it a single inch or you
surrender
and let it have its way with the culture
and we have obviously in this culture
made our choice
and we chose very poorly
let's get now to our five headlines
[Music]
now a quick word from our good friends
over at charity mobile you know it's
never been more important
to support companies that support our
values to support companies that have
morals that
share our values because there's so many
companies out there that obviously don't
and inevitably you're going to be
supporting a lot of companies that don't
share your values
but when there's an opportunity when you
find one
like charity mobile you've got to jump
on it charity mobile is the pro-life
phone company because five percent of
your monthly plan price goes to the
pro-life
pro family charity of your choice you
can help build a culture of life in
america while supporting a pro-life
phone company
and that's you know there there's that
piece of it that's really important
obviously but also we should mention
it's a great service with great uh perks
that come like new activations and
eligible accounts get a
free cell phone with free activation and
free shipping you can there's no
contract no termination fees and no risk
with a 30-day guarantee
uh so that means that there's no reason
to not try out charity mobile
live customer service based right here
in the usa you also have the ability to
block
uh cellular data picture messages so
you've got that parental control as well
that safety that comes with it
so if you want to be a part of charity
mobile call them at 1-877-474-3662 or
chat with them
online at charitymobile.com you know i
have to tell you and this relates to
what we're going to talk about the daily
cancellation and a little bit to what we
just talked about in
the opening monologue but i i am maybe
it's on my mind i have it's
i'm kind of crisis of conscience a
little bit
and it's lent it's a time for atonement
and confession so
um i have to confess to a little bit of
hypocrisy myself
i was playing scrabble with my wife a
few days ago
and um in the early going of the game
she was she was
beating me and she never beats me in
scrabble i take immense pride in
my scrabble prowess and in fact it all
in all in my prowess in all board games
it's all i have it's the only thing i'm
good at is board games and so i i
i cling to those and um finally we get
towards the end of the game and it's
getting
the score's pretty close and uh you know
we're at the
we're at the stage of the game there's
not a lot of room left on the board and
you know you're putting down words like
cat and stuff like that just because
you're trying to get
the titles up and i put down the word
zer z-e-r which is a trans inclusionary
you know gender-neutral
fake pronoun thing and uh but z
10 points i put it on a triple letter
score ended up with 32 points i won the
game on that basis
even though i know it's a made up word
um and i
i did have a moment where i was like
this i'm i am
abandoning everything i believe just to
win this scrabble game
but when it comes to board games i
basically have no morals i will do
anything to win
only in the realm of board games
um but i did win the game and uh that's
yeah that that's
maybe the one good thing about all the
leftist
in manipulation of language is it it is
great for scrabble because they're
adding a lot of z's a lot of x's in and
those are high
scoring tiles right there so that's
maybe the one good thing
all right number one this is from the
new york post it says new york governor
andrew cuomo on monday was accused of
making unwanted advances towards a woman
and planting an unsolicited
kiss on her cheek at a 2019 wedding
anna rutch 33 recalled to the new york
times that he said he said can i kiss
you
i was so confused and shocked and
embarrassed
the allegation comes after two former
state staffers accused cuomo 63 of
sexual harassment on the job including
one who claimed the governor kissed her
without warning
at his manhattan office which she has
denied unlike the other two women rush
has never been employed by the the
governor
or the state according to the times
former member of the obama
administration of 2020
biden campaign russian cuomo met at a
crowded new york city wedding reception
in december 2019.
within moments of being introduced rush
claims the governor put his hands
on the small of her lower back which was
exposed in an open back dress
and she said quote i promptly removed
his hand with my hand which i would have
thought was a clear enough indicator
that i was not wanting him to touch me
the governor apparently didn't get the
hint he allegedly noted that rush seemed
aggressive and then placed his hand on
her cheeks and asked her if he could
kiss her
she said she turned away didn't have
words in that moment there's actually a
picture i think of this moment
where he's got his hands on her cheek
and is talking to her and she looks
extremely uncomfortable
there's been a lot of claims like this
now you know and this is
everyone's turning against him i mean
the media um
everyone's turning against him on this
and this will probably take him down i
think he's probably gonna have to resign
if they if they if they keep up the
pressure
because obviously for andrew cuomo it
doesn't matter conservatives can
complain about them all they want as
we've discovered it's not going to make
a damn bit of difference he's the
governor of new york after all
but when the left turns on you as the
governor of new york well then you've
got you've got nowhere to turn
uh so that's what's happening here
media's turning on them
other elected democrats de blasio
throwing them under the bus
which they hate each other so no
surprise there
but you know i hear this and
i just can't i i can't quite get over
the fact
that this is i'm not surprised okay but
even so this is what takes him down this
not the fact that he killed thousands of
old people
he he through his actions
um thousands of old people died
thousands of elderly people died
because of him and he wins an emmy
and a book deal because of it
um or maybe not because of it but
certainly in spite of it
we we have known about the nursing home
scandal for months now
and even after that came to light the
emmy book deal everything he was
celebrated
left loved him media loved him
so that's no big deal so we say to the
media oh you know this guy he killed ten
thousand elderly people
yeah you know but he also touched a
woman's cheek
well off with his head
you want to talk about priorities i mean
my god
there could be nothing that better
illustrates our backwards priorities in
this country than this story
it it does it does have vibes of like al
capone
getting taken down for tax evasion after
you know everything that he did it's
like it's like a little bit of that
and so that's that's also why people on
the right i think are jumping on this
sexual harassment bandwagon um
because they realize that this pales in
comparison
to the nursing home scandal not even in
the same ballpark not in the same
city not in the same universe right they
realize that but they figure well if
this is what we can take them down with
then let's let's do it
i can't quite jump on that bandwagon
because i can't stomach it
i can't stomach pretending that this
who cares about this when we have this
other thing over here
if i'm gonna spend any time criticizing
andrew cuomo
in my private life or on this show how
could i carve out
time to talk about him saying a woman
can i kiss you
when he killed thousands of elderly
people that's the scandal
100 it's not even like it's mostly that
and a little bit of this no it's all
that
the comments he made to women were it
sounds like some of them were
inappropriate
okay they made some inappropriate
comments great i understand
uh he shouldn't have made those comments
he shouldn't have said them
okay let's go back to talking about all
the dead elderly people
let's talk about the dead people
these women that he made inappropriate
comments do they're they're they're
alive
you know they're they're thriving
they're a lot of people who are not
alive and not thriving today because of
his actions
it is just
it cannot be defended what we're seeing
happen right now
uh that this is what's going to take him
down and this and i'm not defending him
you know i'm not i'm not i'm not looking
to white knight for andrew cuomo here
my only point is if we're screaming
about what a scumbag he is yes he is
a scumbag but it's because of the
nursing home scandal
now um chris cuomo is his uh
younger adoring brother was forced to
sort of acknowledge some of this on his
show yesterday
in a way but in in his
acknowledgment he kind of uh condemned
himself
and let's listen to it now and see what
he says before we start tonight
uh let me say something that i'm sure is
very obvious to you who watched my show
and thank you for that you're straight
with me i'll be straight with you
obviously i'm aware of what's going on
with my brother
and obviously i cannot cover it because
he is my brother now of course
cnn has to cover it they have covered it
extensively and they will continue to do
so
i have always cared very deeply
about these issues and profoundly so
i just wanted to tell you that there's a
lot of news going on that matters
also so let's get after
that okay when he says these issues
covering it these issues are important
he's talking about the inappropriate
comments to him he's talking about
touching a woman's cheek
or her lower back that's what he's
talking about not killing thousands of
elderly people that's he's talking about
the comments that's the issue that
matters
with andrew cuomo now of course the
claim that it's a conflict of interest
so he can't cover it
is absurd because he if it's a conflict
of interest
to talk about a negative story
pertaining to a family member
then isn't it also a conflict of
interest to talk about the supposedly
positive stories talk about how
what a great job he's doing as governor
like as andre as
chris cuomo did for months when he
brought them on for their little buddy
cop
you know slapstick duo routine comedy
routine
complete with uh with props and
everything
if if the one is a conflict of interest
then this is also a conflict of interest
it would seem to me
all right number two so there was a
story that a school district in virginia
was banning dr
seuss on charges that dr seuss was
racist but cnn has the article running
cover for this cancellation attempt
as best they can let me pull it up here
it says a school district in virginia
recently made headlines for allegedly
banning
books uh books by dr seuss but lou down
county public schools located in ashburn
said it is not banning books by the
famous children's author it's just
discouraging a connection between read
across america which was created to get
kids excited about reading
and dr seuss's birthday both follow
march 2nd and have often been
historically connected to each other
according to the district
it said in a statement research in
recent years has revealed strong racial
undertones in many books written
illustrated by dr seuss
and examples of racial undertones in the
books include anti-japanese american
political cartoons and cartoons
depicting african-americans for sale
captioned with offensive language this
according to the lcps
uh given this research and lcps's focus
on equity and culturally responsive
instruction
lcps provided this guidance to schools
during the past couple of years to not
connect read across america day
exclusively
with dr seuss's books so that's the um
that's the claim at least as it pertains
to the school systems and read across
america
that well they're not they're not
canceling the books they're just
de-emphasizing them
which read as canceling them
but it goes beyond the school systems so
here's the latest
um from mediaite this is what they
report
the official organization that controls
the legacy of dr seuss has announced it
will see
sales of six of the author's children's
books over racist and insensitive
depictions
in a statement time for the late
author's birthday
uh dr seuss enterprises told the
associated press that the books here are
the books
and to think that i saw it on may
mulberry street if i ran the zoo
mcelligot's pool on beyond zebra
scrambled egg super and the cat's
quizzer
will no longer be published due to
hurtful depictions in the books
so we've got the school system but then
also
dr seuss enterprises the people that
control dr seuss's legacy control his uh
control everything they're throwing them
under the bus too
they're they're taking part in the
metaphorical book burning that's how bad
it's gotten
you know i see all this now that dr
seuss and of course dr seuss is
cancelled
listen some of us have been have been
warning you
about this for for years now um
every they're coming for everybody
everybody
if you were a prominent person an author
a historical figure
a politician anything
and it's someone who existed well i i i
used to say it was like if it was
if you if you existed 40 years ago or
earlier
you're going to be canceled but now we
could probably move that up and say
if you existed 20 years ago or earlier
10 years ago
everyone's going to get it of course
they're going to come for dr seuss
and yeah if you go back in history you
go back to people author it doesn't
matter anyone
who lived 60 years ago 70 80 90 years
ago
yes they're going to have views
that are not acceptable by our modern
standards
and if they were prominent people
they'll probably have expressed those
views
in some form that's the case for
everyone
there was not a person who lived 80
years ago
who did not have at least one viewpoint
that people in modern society especially
on the left would
recoil in heart uh if they hurt
not not not a single person who lived
even 80 years ago
you want to go back you want to talk
about 200 years ago 300 years ago forget
about it
so now they're coming for dr seuss um
and i do take this somewhat personally
this is a cancellation that hits me you
know
a little bit more than some of the
others because i
as a kid i was a huge dr seuss fan i
partially taught myself to read
using dr seuss books i was i was in the
dr seuss book club i had all the books
and everything um with the
the cat in the hat book enders and then
i had i had the whole i had the whole dr
shoes catalogue up on the
up on our bookshelf in our house and i
would read i love dr seuss as a kid
my kids love dr seuss they're still
gonna love dr seuss
they're coming for him too now and you
know i have always said if we are gonna
cancel dr
seuss um it shouldn't be for racism it
should be if anything it should be for
elder
abuse with the book hop on pop because
that is a really influential to kids and
i've read that to my kids
and now because they've been brainwashed
by that book they think that any time
they see
dad laying on a couch doesn't matter
uh they can just run and jump right on
me elbow right to the gut
i think it has a lot to do with that
book so if we're going to cancel them it
should be for that
all right number three former cia
director john brennan has gone
full critical race theory now not a
surprising development either but here
he is on msnbc let's listen
we started with kate katie benner's
great new reporting about the
investigation to police officer
it renders you know at best hypocritical
at worst cynical and false
any notion that the republicans care
about the lives and the safety of law
enforcement
well i must say to claire's point i'm
increasingly embarrassed to be a white
male these days
and what a lot of what i see of my other
white males saying
but it just shows that with the ex with
very few exceptions like
mitt romney liz cheney adam kinzinger
there are
so few republicans in congress who value
truth
honesty and integrity and so they'll
continue to gaslight the country the way
that donald trump did
and the fact that this has such security
and safety implications
for the american public and for the
members of congress again
as claire said it is just a disgusting
display of craven politics that really
should have no place
in the united states in 2021
yeah he's embarrassed to be a white male
well i got to tell you john feeling's
mutual
we we feel the same same way about you
we feel ashamed of you
you ridiculous goober what is it
what does it tell you that these are the
kinds of people we had running our law
enforcement agencies
the cia you know these kind of people
these empty suits these big fat nothings
you're embarrassed to be a white male
what
what does that mean you you would never
hear
anyone of any other race ever say
anything like that
you'd never hear it
never hear it but with
with with but if you want to be on msnbc
and you're a white male then that's the
sort of
token um atonement you're supposed to uh
supposed to supposed to offer supposed
to display
to show how ashamed you are
i mean eventually that's going to be a
prerequisite for employment at a place
like
msnbc if you're a white male
even get in the door you have to
apologize for being one
and i always think with these guys john
brennan is however
old he is he's an old guy um
and here he is sounding like a
you know a 19 year old girl in a gender
studies class
bought into critical race theory i'm
embarrassed to be a white male
at his age you're supposed to get
firmer and more stubborn in your old age
we've got these these democrats
at their old age they're buying into all
this stuff
because they are again nothing they have
nothing going on inside empty shells
all right number four this is another
one um
kind of a uh related to our priorities
so this is the
who is this the new york post says lady
gaga's
dog walker who was shot while out for a
stroll with the star's french bulldogs
in los angeles
penned an emotional social media post on
monday morning describing the ambush and
thanking the star for her support
ryan fisher uh 39 years old he wrote
this i wrote on instagram it was a
lengthy thing he started talking about
when he was walking the lady gaga's dogs
and the gunman
came shot him in his leg it's a horrible
story he's laying in a pool of his own
blood
and he was he's in the hospital he's
recovering now he was on a breathing
tube i think he's off of the breathing
tube now
um but this story yeah i first saw this
story about lady gaga's dogs getting
kidnapped last week and i thought who
who cares
and what does it tell you that it took
like five days
for anyone to even ask what about the
human being who got shot
do we hear an update on this guy
all the headlines and everything
everyone that was so concerned it was
all about the
dogs getting who cares yeah i'm
concerned about the person
turns out the person is going to be okay
it looks like thank god
this is one of those it just shows me
how little i understand i guess
the american public at this point
because if if i
if someone had come to me with the scoop
on that story if i had let's say
a source in law enforcement in beverly
hills or wherever this was
uh and and they came to me and they said
hey listen we got uh we
lady gaga's dogs are just we're just
kidnapped we're just dog-napped
big story you know you could break the
story i would have said no i'm not gonna
i would have just tossed that one in the
trash bin i would have tossed that tip
in the trash bin
i would have figured that nobody would
care i would say what their dogs were
kidnapped so
am i gonna that's not breaking news
i would have lost that you know that
could have been something that made my
journalistic career if i had got that
story
um people cared a lot
even on drudge report this was the big
story sirens blaring
lady gaga's dogs were kidnapped
of all the things if i were to make a
list
what day did that happen last thursday
if i were to make a list of of
every news item from last thursday and
rank it by importance
lady gaga's dogs getting canceled would
literally be
the very last item on that list
all right um but the dogs were recovered
by the way
if you're concerned about that so the
dogs are okay person was shot
and that's that story all right number
five the daily mail has this
says work is due to start on the world's
first
space hotel in low earth orbit in 2025
and it will come equipped with
restaurants a cinema spa
and rooms for 400 people developed by
the orbital assembly corporation the
voyager station could be operational as
early as 2027
with the infrastructure built in orbit
around the earth
that seems a little bit optimistic to me
but they're hoping to have they're
hoping to have a a
space hotel fully operational in the
next seven years
my only question is how much would it
cost to have a pizza delivered to your
room
sorry i just read this story just for
that joke the whole story was leading up
to that bad joke and i apologize for
that but that's all i have to say about
that that's it
all right let's go to uh reading the
comments now this is from anna
she says we know that public schools
have failed us because apparently the
only historic event anyone ever learned
was about world war
ii can anyone ever come up with a
historic reference from any other time
period
is exactly what that's the only thing
that offends me about the constant
nazi comparisons is just how
there are so many other historical
events and oftentimes the thing you're
comparing to the nazis
there is a historical analog it's just
not that
so i agree with you uh jonathan says
came for ben
laughed with clavin learned a little
from knowles staying sane with matt
so you're saying you don't laugh with me
or learn from me
you're banned from the show how dare you
um
i'm so damn gucci says matt this may be
unrelated but i want to know what do you
think about amateur predator catching
groups
i guess child predator catching groups
and if their evidence should be allowed
in a court of law
uh yeah i'm in
there's probably no measure being taken
against child predators that i would
object to
and there are a lot of measures not
being taken right now that if they were
taken i also would not object to
so um i'm i'm fine with it whatever
whatever can be done to bring these
scumbags down is cool with me
uh johann broham says i think that matt
walsh would be a fantastic press
secretary
matt walsh press secretary 2024 i would
be terrible at that job
i would be i would be worse than jen
pasaki
um which maybe that's what you mean by
great is that you would enjoy watching
me
you would enjoy watching the uh crap
show up on
up on your screen every day so if that's
what you mean then i guess you're right
vincent andrews says
matt you're not going to read this
comment aria no i'm not um
and stabby troll a lot of great
usernames
today stabby troll says stop please stop
telling people that the leftists call
everything nazi without explaining every
single time
that they call others nazis to hide the
fact that they are nazis
it just makes people who don't know the
insurgency tactics feel bad and believe
them
this is exactly there's a nice book end
here nice symmetry
first comment to the last because you
stabby troll
are demonstrating what was observed uh
astutely by the person in the first
comment that
no the the leftists are not nazis
there's many things you could say about
them
many bad things many criticisms you can
offer i spend all day every day offering
those criticisms
but they're not nazis no they have
very little there's very little
comparison that could be made
i mean a few things both leftist and
nazis were both
environmentalists for example big into
animal rights
um if nobody else's rights but no
there's there's no there's no real
comparison
um so we it's it's not about you know
being offended it's just if you're
looking for historical analogies
find one that makes sense
because the the only thing you mean by
that when you say they're the nazis
what you mean is nazis are bad
and leftists are bad and so they're the
same
but that's not right even if you want to
go back to what
there's there's a better comparisons to
be made between leftists
and like the soviets if you want to go
back to that period in history and look
for an analog then i think that's where
you would want to look
so now let's talk about rock auto you
hear me talk about rock auto all the
time because they're just a great
company
and a great service and they're all
about saving you time and money which
when you're shopping for auto parts i
think that's that's
what you're looking to do right you want
to find the right product but but you
don't want to waste more time than you
need to or spend more money than you
have to
rockauto.com is so much easier than
walking into a store
and you got to answer all the questions
from the guy behind the counter maybe he
doesn't have what you need he's got to
go online he's got to order your part
he says it'll be in in five to six
business days or whatever you have
access to rockauto.com
at your desk and in your pocket why not
take advantage of it rockauto.com always
offers the lowest prices possible rather
than changing prices based on what the
market will bear like airlines do
rockauto.com is a family business
they've been doing this for a long time
for 20 years they've been serving
auto parts customers online you can go
to rockauto.com to shop for auto and
body parts from hundreds of
manufacturers
best of all the prices at rockauto.com
are always reliably low
and they're the same no matter if you're
professional do it yourself or
they're gonna be the same they're not
gonna charge you they're gonna charge
you as little
as they possibly can to make sure you
get what you need amazing selection
reliably low prices
all the parts your car will ever need
rockauto.com go to rockauto.com right
now see all the parts available for your
car truck remember to write walsh in
there how did you hear about us box
so they know that we sent you also so
many crazy leftist theories uh out there
and in some cases outright lies of
course
need to be called out for what they are
and that's exactly what ben shapiro does
every day but this is what he's
especially doing in the daily wires
newest series debunked
every friday ben exposes popular
fallacies purported by
leftist activists and politicians in the
first episode they talked about uh
the minimum wage there's a great episode
he debunks the myth of the minimum wage
i'm sure you've heard this argument
before we need a livable minimum wage
what liberal activists and politicians
won't acknowledge however is that the
minimum wage was never designed to be
a livable wage and it hurts more people
than it helps so he talks about that and
so many other subjects debunked is
available exclusively to daily wire
members so go to dailywire.com
subscribe and use code debunked to get
25
off your new membership and stay tuned
for this friday's episode where ben will
break down unions
so looking forward to that that's code
debunked for 25
off now let's get to our daily
cancellation
so we begin today with the streaming
platform twitch as i understand it
twitch is a place where people play
video games
and other people watch those people
playing video games i find this concept
utterly mystifying i mean this is what
i'm up against you understand
it was hard enough for me to wrap my
head around why anyone plays video games
to begin with now
now i have to try to understand why
people not only play them
but watch other people play them i mean
what's next will you listen to a podcast
where someone describes themselves
playing a video game in real time
unless that's already a thing is that
already a thing
please tell me that's not already a
thing but we can we can return to that
issue another time i guess the reason
twitch is appearing in the daily
cancellation for this episode is a tweet
they sent out yesterday in honor of
women's history month this is just to
emphasize
women's history month if you didn't know
that coming up in a week march 8th is
also international women's day
and that falls in the middle of
international women's week
so it will be women's day during women's
week during women's month
and i'm still concerned that we may not
be appreciating women enough i think we
need
maybe a women's hour a women's hour
on women's day during women's week and
women's month this is how we will defeat
sexism once and for all
now twitch tried to do their part they
tweeted quote
join us in celebrating and supporting
all the women creating their own worlds
building their communities and leading
the way
on twitch seems pretty standard the
problem is that they spelled women with
an x
mixin which is i guess how that's
supposed to be pronounced
this is supposed to be the
gender-neutral trans-inclusionary
spelling of women similar to latinx
the gender-neutral trans-inclusionary
spelling of latino
and spaghetti x which is the
gender-neutral trans-inclusionary
spelling of spaghettios
and you can go on and on but twitch's
inclusionary gambit didn't pay off there
was massive backlash to it not from the
right
but from the left thousands of leftists
complain that wimxin
though intended to include trans people
actually excludes them
trans women are women as the claim goes
if you change the word women to include
them then you're not really including
them at all
and of course they're right it's sort of
like if you're a kid and some other kids
have a group they call the best friends
club
and you ask if you can join it so they
say sure but then they change the name
to
the casual acquaintances club i mean
it's nice they're trying to bring you
into the fold but the message they send
by changing the name is that they aren't
really bringing you into the fault at
all at least not the same one that you
wanted to be in
so a similar thing is happening here but
of course that's not the problem with
adding
x to women the problem is not that it
makes trans people feel singled out i
mean
just adding trans to women already does
that
the very word trans already makes clear
that trans women are not the same as
actual women if they were
we just call them women the very fact
that you have to say the phrase
trans women are women tells me that they
aren't
in any case none of that is the point
the point and the problem with wimixin
is that it's gibberish so is latinx
so are the new pronouns that get shoved
into the lexicon every day
this is all gibberish and that's the
problem with it
the left objected to wimxin while still
not objecting to latinx or any similar
innovation
uh not because it it's invented
gibberish but because it is invented
gibberish that didn't have the political
and ideological effect that they
intended
that's a very different sort of
criticism my issue my criticism with
people speaking gibberish is simply that
it is gibberish
and gibberish when we're forced to
pretend that it's not gibberish
is an assault on human language
now the defense usually offered for this
kind of thing is that language evolves
right people sound
different today than they did 50 years
ago or 100 years ago
and so on words change meaning over time
new words new expressions are adopted
it's the evolution of language
and it's true that language does evolve
but la tinx is not a
product of evolution neither is wemixin
these are changes that are engineered
artificially and for expressly
ideological reasons it is not evolution
but design
though perhaps not very intelligent
design normally
language evolves so that different
people in different eras can better
express
their meaning and better be understood
but these artificial changes have the
opposite effect and intent
they make speech less clear meaning more
obscured
and that's why it should be opposed not
for the reason that the left
opposed this particular change but for
the real reason that it is simply
gibberish but twitch somehow managed to
attract the ire of both left and right
i mean they managed to be so
aggressively stupid and hopelessly woke
that even their fellow maniacs were
coiled
and if that's not worthy of cancellation
then i don't know what is
and so twitch is officially uh
cancelled and also because look what are
you doing sitting around watching other
people play video games
like read a book go for a jog okay go
climb a tree or something
by the way twitch is canceled okay we'll
leave it there thanks for watching
thanks for listening have a great day
godspeed
[Music]
the matt wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling our technical
director is austin stevens
production manager pavel vadosky the
show is edited by danny d'amico
our audio is mixed by mike coromina hair
and makeup is done by nika geneva
and our production coordinator is
mckenna waters the matte wall show is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire 20 21.
a thruple of men are all listed as
fathers on a child's birth certificate
minneapolis goes on lockdown ahead of
the george floyd trial
and moderate joe biden pushes more
radicalism check it out on the michael
knowles show
[Music]